(piano music)
(record scratch)
- Hey.
- Oh, hey. How's it going?
- Oh, uh.
- Um, do you want--?
- Uh, yeah. We can...
Hug and a handshake, alright!
- Great.
- OK...
- Hey.
- Happy birthday.
- Oh thanks, Claire. You too.
- I won't be able to.
- You're always really busy though.
(gasps)
- I'm so sorry!
- That's my fault...
- Oh my God.
- No. No!
No!
Aww...
- It was great meeting you, Joe.
Thanks for coming in.
- Thanks so much for having me.
- Absolutely.
I think you're going to be
a great candidate for this position.
Do you have any questions for me?
- Uh, yeah, just...
Who do I have to interview
with to get your job?
(awkward laugh)
- I don't...
- Totally the best movie of the year--
(loud thud)
Ow!
That's OK.
- Can I still put the number in?
- Yeah, of course.
- I'm sorry.